SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO, GIL ARCHULETA.
ASHBY. ATKINS BECKER. BLAKE.
SPEER BRADFORD. CABALLERO
CORTEZ. DALLY DODD. THÀNH RAZO.
EGGMAN. GLASER GONZALEZ. GROVE
HURTADO. JONES. LAIRD LIMÓN.
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. MEN NEWMAN.
NGUYEN NILO. OKOBO. PADILLA
PORTANTINO. ROTH RUBIO. SATO.
SKINNER SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
STERN. UMBERG WAHAB. WIENER.
WILK A QUORUM IS PRESENT, AND.
SENATORS, IF WE CAN RETURN TO
OUR DESK AND STAND UP WITH THE
MEMBERS AND GUESTS, BE ON THE
ROW IN THE GALLERY. PLEASE RISE.
WE WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING BY OUR CHAPLAIN, SISTER
MICHELLE GORMAN, AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING FOR THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. THANK YOU.
AS WE GATHER IN GOD'S PRESENCE,
WE PRAY TODAY FROM THE WISDOM OF
THE SUFIS. OH, LORD, GIVE ME
EYES WHICH SEE NOTHING BUT YOUR
GLORY. GIVE ME A MIND THAT FINDS
DELIGHT IN YOUR SERVICE. GIVE ME
A SOUL DRUNK IN THE WINE OF YOUR
WISDOM. OH LORD, THOUGH THE BLUE
FLOWER BE POISONOUS. IF IT IS OF
YOUR GARDEN. AND IF SO, AND SO
BE A SINNER. HE IS OF YOUR
PEOPLE. LORD, WHEN YOU WERE
HIDDEN FROM ME, THE FEVER OF
LIFE POSSESSED ME. WHEN YOU
REVEAL YOURSELF, THIS FEVER OF
LIFE DEPARTS. OH, LORD,
INTOXICATE ME WITH THE WINE OF
YOUR LOVE. MAKE ME EMPTY OF ALL
BUT YOUR LOVE. AMEN PLEASE JOIN
ME IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA. TO THE
REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT STANDS.
ONE NATION UNDER GOD,
INDIVISIBLE, WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION, WE WILL BE TAKING UP
THE FOLLOWING RESOLUTION. OUT OF
ORDER TODAY. FILE ITEM 27 SR
105. AFTER ADOPTION OF THE
RESOLUTION, WE WILL REMOVE. WE
WILL MOVE TO PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR FOR THE AUTHOR TO
INTRODUCE THEIR GUEST. STARTING
WITH ITEM 27, SENATOR NEWMAN IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
SENATE RESOLUTION 105 BY SENATOR
NEWMAN RELATIVE TO PAKISTANI
AMERICAN RELATIONS. SENATOR
NEWMAN, THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. IT'S MY GREAT
PRIVILEGE TO PRESENT SR 105,
WHICH COMMEMORATES THE CLOSE AND
ENDURING RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
THE UNITED STATES AND PAKISTAN
AND WHICH RECOGNIZES THE
INNUMERABLE CONTRIBUTIONS MADE
BY CALIFORNIA'S PAKISTANI
AMERICAN COMMUNITY IN ADVANCE OF
THE CELEBRATION OF PAKISTAN'S
INDEPENDENCE DAY NEXT WEDNESDAY,
AUGUST. THE 14TH. AS HOME TO A
DYNAMIC AND RAPIDLY GROWING
COMMUNITY OF MORE THAN 75,000,
THE STORY OF CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
INDELIBLY SHAPED BY THE
INGENUITY, ASPIRATIONS AND
PERSEVERANCE OF OUR PAKISTANI
AMERICAN COMMUNITY. FOR DECADES,
THEY HAVE COME TO CALIFORNIA AS
STUDENTS, DOCTORS, ENGINEERS AND
ENTREPRENEURS, EACH WITH THEIR
OWN DREAM AND DETERMINATION TO
SUCCEED FROM THEIR INNOVATIVE
WORK, LEADING AND POWERING THE
TECH START UPS OF SILICON VALLEY
TO MANAGING THE THRIVING SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT ENRICH OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. CALIFORNIA'S
PAKISTANI AMERICAN COMMUNITY HAS
HELPED FUEL THE GOLDEN STATE'S
REPUTATION AS BOTH A GLOBAL TECH
HUB AND ECONOMIC POWER, AND AS A
DIVERSE AND VIBRANT PLACE TO
LIVE AT. NO POINT IS THAT
DIVERSE HERITAGE MORE EVIDENT
THAN IN THE LIVELY CELEBRATIONS
OF PAKISTANI INDEPENDENCE DAY.
NEXT WEDNESDAY. IN COMMUNITIES
UP AND DOWN THE STATE, OUR
PAKISTANI AMERICAN NEIGHBORS
WILL BE COMMEMORATING PAKISTAN'S
77TH INDEPENDENCE DAY. THESE
CELEBRATIONS NOT ONLY AFFORD
CALIFORNIANS A GLIMPSE INTO
PAKISTANI CULTURE, BUT THEY
OFFER US AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REFLECT UPON THE LONG STANDING
STRATEGIC RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
PAKISTAN AND THE UNITED STATES,
A RELATIONSHIP THAT IS BUILT NOT
JUST ON BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
ANNUAL TRADE, BUT ON A SHARED
DESIRE FOR REGIONAL SECURITY AND
STABILITY, AND ON A MUTUAL
RESPECT FOR DEMOCRATIC VALUES
AND THE IMPORTANCE OF HUMAN
RIGHTS. COLLEAGUES, PLEASE JOIN
ME IN SUPPORTING SR 105 AS A WAY
TO INSPIRE BOTH CURRENT AND
FUTURE GENERATIONS TO TAKE PRIDE
IN THEIR RICH CULTURAL HERITAGE
AND REMIND US ALL HOW
IMMIGRATION AND CULTURAL
EXCHANGES ENRICH OUR STATE AND
MAKE CALIFORNIA SUCH A VIBRANT
AND WELCOMING PLACE TO LIVE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON SR 105 TODAY. THANK YOU
SENATOR, ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE RESOLUTION?
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN, I ALVARADO, GIL I
ARCHULETA I ASHBY I ATKINS.
BECKER I BLAKE SPEER I BRADFORD
I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLEY
DODD I DURAZZO I EGGMAN I GLASER
I GONZALEZ I GROVE I HURTADO I
JONES I LAIRD I LIMON I MCGUIRE
I MENGIBAR I MIN I NEWMAN I
NGUYEN NILO I OCHOA PADILLA I
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO. RUBIO
I SATO I SKINNER I SMALL. CUEVAS
I STERN UMBERG I WAHAB I WIENER
I WILK. SENATOR NEWMAN MOVES A
CALL. SENATOR NEWMAN, PLEASE
PROCEED WITH YOUR INTRODUCTION
OF YOUR GUEST AND THANK YOU,
COLLEAGUES, JOINING US THIS
MORNING TO CELEBRATE AS THE
CONSUL GENERAL OF PAKISTAN IN
LOS ANGELES, ASEEM ALI KHAN.
SINCE JOINING THE PAKISTANI
FOREIGN SERVICE IN 2003, MR.
KHAN HAS HELD KEY DIPLOMATIC
POSITIONS IN CANADA, FRANCE,
CHINA AND NOW IN THE UNITED
STATES. CONSUL GENERAL HAHN IS
ACCOMPANIED BY OTHER PROMINENT
MEMBERS OF THE PAKISTANI,
AMERICAN COMMUNITY, WHO HAVE
DEDICATED THEMSELVES TO
EXPANDING THE TIES BETWEEN OUR
TWO COUNTRIES AND ENSURING THAT
PAKISTANI VOICES ARE INCLUDED IN
OUR STATE'S STORY. THEY INCLUDE
DOCTOR IMRAN SHARIF, HIS WIFE
ITRAT SHARIF, MY FRIEND ADNAN
KHAN, UZAIR HASSAN, ISMAIL
SHAKIBAI, FIROZ SALEEM, ADILA
MONIS SAYED AND ASAD KHAN.
PLEASE GIVE THEM A VERY WARM
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE WELCOME.
WELCOME TO THE STATE SENATE.
IF ANYONE ELSE WISHES TO BE PART
OF THIS GROUP PHOTO, NOW IS THE
TIME. INTRODUCE YOURSELVES TO
OUR ESTEEMED GUEST. SENATOR
ARCHULETA, YOU ARE NEEDED IN THE
BACK.
15 SECONDS. WE'LL RECONVENE IN
15 SECONDS. MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING
TO BE DOING A COUPLE OF THINGS
OUT OF ORDER. WE ARE JUMPING TO
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING RIGHT
NOW. BEFORE WE KICK OFF WITH THE
FINAL ITEMS UNDER ASSEMBLY.
THIRD READING. MR. PRO TEM, YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. MADAM PRESIDENT,
GOOD MORNING AND COLLEAGUES.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO SAY
BRIEF INTRODUCTION ON THE BILLS
THAT WE'RE ABOUT TO TAKE UP. I
RESPECTFULLY RISE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THE RETAIL THEFT
CRIME BILLS THAT ARE A PART OF
OUR BICAMERAL PACKAGE TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA SAFER AND STRONGER.
THE PROPOSALS THAT ARE GOING TO
BE IN FRONT OF US TODAY ARE
ASSEMBLY BILLS. WE'LL HAVE OUR
SENATE BILLS BACK FROM THE
ASSEMBLY ON MONDAY, AND EACH OF
THOSE BILLS ARE DEEPLY
IMPACTFUL. AND I'M GRATEFUL. I'M
GRATEFUL FOR THE EXCHANGE OF
IDEAS AND PROPOSALS FROM ALL
SIDES OF THE AISLE. AND I WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU SO MUCH TO OUR
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES AND OUR
DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR
WORK ON THESE IMPORTANT BILLS.
THESE BILLS ARE GOING TO MAKE
OUR COMMUNITIES SAFER AND TO
HELP BLUNT RETAIL THEFT AT
STORES BIG AND SMALL. IN ALL
CORNERS OF THIS STATE. AND I'D
LIKE TO BRIEFLY TALK ABOUT WHAT
THE ASSEMBLY AND SENATE BILLS
WILL DO, WHICH ARE SUPPORTED BY
THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION, WHICH REPRESENTS
LARGE NATIONAL BASED COMPANIES,
AND MOM AND POP CORNER STORES IN
EACH OF OUR COMMUNITIES. NUMBER
ONE, IT'S GOING TO TACKLE RETAIL
THEFT AND CAR BREAK INS. NUMBER
TWO, CRACKDOWN ON ORGANIZED
CRIME, PREVENT THE SALE OF
STOLEN GOODS, AS WELL AS
ENHANCED SENTENCING FOR
PROFESSIONAL THIEVES. NOW, LET'S
BE HONEST, THIS HAS BEEN A WINDY
ROAD, A WINDY ROAD GETTING TO
THIS POINT, TAKING UP THESE
IMPACTFUL PIECES OF LEGISLATION.
BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS THIS
THESE BILLS ARE CAREFULLY
CONSIDERED. THEY'RE DATA DRIVEN,
SUPPORTED BY LAW ENFORCEMENT,
ADDICTION SPECIALISTS, PUBLIC
SAFETY OFFICIALS AND WILL CRACK
DOWN ON ORGANIZED CRIME. AND
AGAIN, MADAM PRESIDENT, I AM
GRATEFUL FOR THE ENGAGEMENT OF
ALL SIDES OF THE AISLE. WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU, MR. PRO TEM, FOR YOUR
REMARKS. COLLEAGUES, WE HAVE
FIVE ITEMS UNDER A SUMMARY.
THIRD READING. SO YOU'RE
PREPARED. FILE ITEM 137 141,
142, 143 AND 271. KICK IS
KICKING US OFF WITH ITEM 137 ON
AB. 1972 IS GOING TO BE SENATOR
WILK. SENATOR WILK IS PREPARED.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL 1972 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALANIS. AN ACT RELATING TO THEFT
AND DECLARING THE URGENCY
THEREOF TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR WILK. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I RISE TO
PRESENT AB 1972 ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALANIS. THIS
BILL AIMS TO SIGNIFICANTLY
BOLSTER OUR STATE'S RESPONSE TO
CARGO THEFT. AB 1972 BUILDS UPON
THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL'S
REGIONAL PROPERTY CRIMES TASK
FORCE, PROVIDING TARGETED
SUPPORT TO COUNTIES EXPERIENCING
HIGH LEVELS OF CARGO THEFT.
ADDITIONALLY, THE BILL REQUIRES
THAT THE CHP EXTEND PERSONNEL,
EQUIPMENT, AND OTHER RESOURCES
TO RAILROAD POLICE, ENHANCING
THEIR EFFORTS TO COMBAT CARGO
THEFT AS PART OF THE BROADER
LEGISLATIVE RETAIL THEFT BILL
PACKAGE, AB 1972 ALIGNS WITH THE
STATE'S EFFORTS TO STRENGTHEN
STATE LAWS AND OFFER CRUCIAL
ASSISTANCE TO BOTH BUSINESSES
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT WHO ARE
GRAPPLING WITH ONGOING RETAIL
THEFT CRIMES. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. I SEE NO MIX
UP, NO DISCUSSION, DEBATE
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS DOES HAVE AN URGENCY
CLAUSE. REQUIRES 27 VOTES. ALLEN
Ã ALVARADO. GILL. AYE
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEAR
AYE. BRADFORD. AYE CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALLI. AYE
DODD. AYE. DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN
AYE. GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE AYE. HURTADO AYE. JONES.
AYE LAIRD. AYE. LEMON AYE.
MAGUIRE MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE.
NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NEELO
AYE. OKOBO AYE. PADILLA. AYE
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO.
AYE SATO. AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE STERN.
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER
AYE. WILK AYE. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS. MCGUIRE
AYE. STERN AYES 38. NO ZERO ON
THE URGENCY. EIS 38. NO'S ZERO.
MEASURE. PASSES. MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM 141. SENATOR NEWMAN IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 1779 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IRWIN. AN ACT RELATING TO
CRIMES. SEN. NEWMAN. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. I RISE ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER JACKIE
IRWIN TO PRESENT AB 1779, WHICH
IS ALSO A PART OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S CALIFORNIANS
TOGETHER AGAINST RETAIL CRIME
PACKAGE OF BILLS. ORGANIZED
RETAIL THEFT CONTINUES TO PLAGUE
OUR COMMUNITIES, AND THE
RESULTING FINANCIAL IMPACTS
BURDEN NOT JUST RETAILERS BUT
THE AVERAGE CALIFORNIA FAMILY AS
WELL. BY SHIFTING THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH RETAIL THEFT
ONTO ALL OF US, THIS BILL WILL
RESTORE THE ABILITY OF LOCAL
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS TO
CONSOLIDATE CHARGES FROM
MULTIPLE COUNTIES INTO A SINGLE
SET OF CHARGES AT TRIAL, WHEN
PROSECUTING ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT RINGS ACROSS MULTIPLE
JURISDICTIONS, AB 1779 AND THE
REST OF THE BILLS IN THE PACKAGE
OF ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT BILLS
MOVING TODAY ARE INTENDED TO
WORK TOGETHER TO HOLD CRIMINALS
ACCOUNTABLE, WHILE PROVIDING
RELIEF TO RETAILERS AND
CONSUMERS ALIKE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU, SENATOR NEWMAN. I'M
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTION? SEEING NONE. AYES 38.
NØ ZERO. RESOLUTION PASSES.
MOVING RIGHT ALONG. MEASURE BILL
PASSES. BILL PASSES. MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM 142. SEN IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 1802 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JONES-SAWYER. AN ACT
RELATING TO CRIMES. SENATOR
WAHAB, THANK YOU COLLEAGUES AND
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. I RISE TO
PRESENT AB 1802 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JOAN SAWYER, WHICH WILL
ELIMINATE THE SUNSET OF THE
CRIME OF ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT
AND THE OPERATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
PROPERTY CRIMES TASK FORCE. THIS
BILL IS PART OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S ROBUST PACKAGE OF
BILLS THAT COMPREHENSIVELY
ADDRESS RETAIL THEFT IN
CALIFORNIA. AB 1802 WILL ENSURE
THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS THE
NECESSARY MEANS TO ARREST AND
PROSECUTE THE ORGANIZED CRIME
RINGS THAT CONTINUE TO DISRUPT
THE QUALITY OF LIFE IN
CALIFORNIA. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR. NO SEE, NO MIX UP. THIS
ITEM IS ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTION? I SEE NONE AYES 38.
NO ZERO. THE BILL PASSES. WE'RE
ZOOMING ON TO THE NEXT ONE. FILE
ITEM 143. SENATOR WIENER IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL 3209 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN. AN ACT RELATING
TO CRIMES. SENATOR WIENER. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 3209 ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN. THIS BILL PROVIDES A NEW
ENFORCEMENT TOOL TO HELP KEEP
STORES AND WORKERS SAFE WHILE
ADDRESSING RETAIL THEFT. THE
BILL AUTHORIZES A COURT TO
IMPOSE A RETAIL CRIME
RESTRAINING ORDER OF UP TO TWO
YEARS FOR THEFT, VANDALISM, OR
BATTERY ON AN EMPLOYEE WITHIN
THE STORE. THE BILL STRIKES A
BALANCE BETWEEN PROVIDING AN
ADDITIONAL ENFORCEMENT TOOL TO
KEEP STORES, CUSTOMERS, AND
WORKERS SAFE. WHILE NOT
PERPETUATING THE UNDERLYING
CAUSES OF RETAIL THEFT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR. I SEE
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. ONCE
AGAIN, THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTION? I CONTINUE TO SEE
NONE. EYES 38 NÓ ZERO. THE BILL
PASSES OUR FINAL ITEM ON
ASSEMBLY. THIRD READING IS FINAL
ITEM 271. SENATOR WIENER IS ONCE
AGAIN PREPARED. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL 2943
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ZEBRA. AN ACT
RELATING TO CRIMES. SENATOR
WIENER, THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MADAM PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT AB 2943.
THE CALIFORNIA RETAIL THEFT
REDUCTION ACT ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ZUBIATE AND HIS
JOINT AUTHOR SPEAKER RIVAS. THIS
BILL IS A PRODUCT OF
COLLABORATION AMONG THE
SPEAKER'S OFFICE, SENATE
LEADERSHIP, GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
AND POLICY EXPERTS INCLUDING
RETAILERS, WORKERS, CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM ADVOCATES AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT. THE BILL TARGETS
SERIAL RETAIL THEFT BY CREATING
A NEW CRIME FOR PEOPLE WHO
ENGAGE IN REPEATED, SPECIFIED
CONDUCT OR WHO POSSESS A
QUANTITY OF GOODS INCONSISTENT
WITH PERSONAL USE AND CONSISTENT
WITH THE INTENT TO RESELL. THE
BILL ALSO MORE SPECIFICALLY
DEFINES HOW THE VALUE OF THEFTS
FROM VARIOUS VICTIMS CAN BE
AGGREGATED TO CHARGE GRAND THEFT
AB 2943 STRIKES A BALANCE
BETWEEN PROVIDING LAW
ENFORCEMENT WITH TOOLS TO
ADDRESS SERIAL SHOPLIFTING,
WHILE INCORPORATING GUARDRAILS
AGAINST FRIVOLOUS ARRESTS. THE
BILL PROTECTS WORKERS, SMALL
BUSINESSES AND THE PUBLIC WHILE
ENSURING THAT WE DO NOT
CRIMINALIZE THOSE WHO ARE
SHOPLIFTING. TO SURVIVE, WE NEED
TO PURSUE REFORMS THAT ARE
EFFECTIVE AT TARGETING RETAIL
CRIME WHILE AVOIDING A ROLLBACK
OF EXISTING REFORMS THAT HAVE
MADE MEANINGFUL CHANGE AND
REDUCED STATEWIDE COSTS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR. I SEE
TWO MICS UP. WE'RE GOING TO
START OFF WITH SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE, TODAY, I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB 2943. I HAVE MET
WITH MANY GROUPS IN MY COMMUNITY
FROM POLICE CHIEFS, SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS, FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHO REALLY
NEED US TO STEP UP IN THIS
ISSUE. AND I'M SO PROUD THAT WE
HAVE ARE PUSHING THIS PACKAGE
FORWARD. THEY ALL SAY THE SAME
THING. WE MUST DO MORE TO STOP
RETAIL THEFT. IT IS HAVING A
DETRIMENTAL IMPACT IN OUR
COMMUNITIES IN THE WAY OF LOSS
OF JOBS, ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY
AND ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
FEELING IT. THIS IS A GOOD BILL
THAT MAKES IT EASIER FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO HOLD SHOPLIFTERS
ACCOUNTABLE, ESPECIALLY THOSE
BAD ACTORS THAT CONTINUE TO GO
BACK AND TARGET OUR SMALL MOM
AND POP STORES AND OTHER BIG
RETAILERS AND AGAIN, WE SEE THE
LOSS OF JOB AND OPPORTUNITY FOR
OUR RESIDENTS. I AM SO PROUD OF
THIS PACKAGE. IT IS A PRIORITY
FOR ALL OF US TO ENSURE THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE SAFE, AND THAT
WE WILL CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
COMMONSENSE BILLS LIKE THIS THAT
ACCOMPLISH SAFE COMMUNITIES. SO,
ON BEHALF OF OUR COMMUNITY,
SMALL MOM AND POP STORES AND ALL
CALIFORNIANS, I URGE AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
SENATOR CUEVAS, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES, I RISE
TODAY IN OPPOSITION TO AB 2943,
AND I APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUE'S
PERSPECTIVE. IN TERMS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES ADDRESSING AND
DEALING WITH CRIME. BUT I JUST
WANT TO REMIND US THIS IS A
SANKOFA MOMENT WHERE WE HAVE TO
GO BACK AND LOOK AT THE PAST IN
ORDER TO KNOW WHERE WE'RE MOVING
AHEAD IN THE FUTURE. AND THIS
MEASURE AND OTHERS LIKE IT ARE
MAKING OUR COMMUNITIES UNSAFE
BECAUSE THESE MEASURES DEEPEN
MASS INCARCERATION AND DEEPENING
MASS INCARCERATION IS GOING IN
REVERSE OF WHERE CALIFORNIANS
WANTED US TO GO, WHICH IS TO
DECARCERATE AND REMOVE
CALIFORNIA AS THE STATE'S
CAPITAL OF INCARCERATION, OF
EXTRACTING RESOURCES THAT COULD
ACTUALLY MAKE COMMUNITIES SAFER.
AND WHAT MAKES OUR COMMUNITY
SAFE? GOOD JOBS, GOOD SCHOOLS,
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE, THE
THINGS THAT WE ARE FIGHTING FOR
EVERY DAY. THESE ARE THE THINGS
THAT MAKE MY COMMUNITY SAFE. AND
I KNOW BECAUSE I REPRESENT SOUTH
CENTRAL LOS ANGELES, WHERE WE
HAVE AN OVERREPRESENTATION OF
POLICE PRESENCE, WHERE WE HAVE
AN OVERREPRESENTATION OF
SURVEILLANCE, WHAT WE HAVE AN
OVERREPRESENTATION OF OUR
RESIDENTS BEHIND BARS, 5% OF
BLACK FOLKS IN THIS STATE LIVE
AS RESIDENTS. ALMOST 30% OF US
ARE BEHIND BARS. FAMILY
COLLEAGUES, IF WE GET ON THIS
ROAD. AND I AM NOT DENYING THE
SHOPLIFTING IS WRONG, I AM NOT
DENYING THAT RETAIL THEFT MUST
BE ADDRESSED. I AM NOT DENYING
THAT CRIMES OF POVERTY IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO FIX. BUT IF WE
GO DOWN THIS ROAD OF PUTTING
FOLKS BEHIND BARS FOR BASIC
PROPERTY CRIMES, NONVIOLENT
CRIMES, SUBSTANCE ABUSE
DISORDER, AND I KNOW BECAUSE I
GREW UP IN THE 90S, I HAD
RELATIVES THAT WERE PUT AWAY
JUST BECAUSE THEY WERE ADDICTED
TO CRACK COCAINE, MISSING THEIR
CHILDREN, THEIR GRANDCHILDREN.
AND ONCE THEY GOT OUT WEARING A
SCARLET LETTER THAT PREVENTED
THEM FROM GETTING A JOB.
CREATING MORE CONDITIONS OF
INSECURITY AND UNSAFETY. AND SO
I JUST WANT TO SAY TO YOU, AS WE
ARE MOVING THESE BILLS FORWARD,
WE WERE MOVING A BALANCED
APPROACH. WE WERE MOVING IN A
DIRECTION WHERE WE WERE MOVING
THESE BILLS TO MAKE COMMUNITIES
SAFE AND PROTECTING PROP 47 AND
THE RIGHT FOR FOLKS TO REENTER
WITH DIGNITY AND TO REALLY
ADDRESS INCARCERATION. BUT WE'RE
NOT THERE NOW. AND SO I CANNOT
SUPPORT THIS BILL AS IT IS
TODAY, BECAUSE THIS IS GOING TO
CREATE A SITUATION WHERE OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE LESS SAFE. LET'S
CONTINUE THE WORK THAT WE'RE
DOING TO BUILD UP THE REAL
SAFETY NET, THE REAL MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES, THE REAL
ANTI-POVERTY PROGRAMS, THE REAL
IN REENTRY AND WORKFORCE
OPPORTUNITIES LIKE GETTING OUR
FOLKS WHO HAVE BEEN, DEALING
WITH ISSUES OF POVERTY INTO GOOD
JOBS, BUILDING A CLIMATE
RESILIENT FUTURE FOR CALIFORNIA
VERSUS SHUTTING THE DOOR,
THROWING AWAY THE KEY, AND
BEGINNING TO AMASS MORE AND MORE
EXTRACTIONS OUT OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. I ASK MY FELLOW
COLLEAGUES HERE, RESPECTFULLY
ASK A NO VOTE ON AB 2943. THANK
YOU, SENATOR CUEVAS. SENATOR
UMBERG, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES I
NOTE THE COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES, AND
I THINK THEY'RE WELL-TAKEN
BECAUSE THIS BILL DOES INDEED
INCREASE PENALTIES. IT'S NOT MY
GOAL, AND I HOPE IT'S NOT OUR
COLLECTIVE GOAL TO PUT MORE
PEOPLE IN PRISON. BUT I WOULD
HOPE OUR GOAL IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE ESPECIALLY EARLY ON,
WHO ARE COMMITTING MINOR CRIMES,
ARE DIVERTED, DIVERTED TO
COLLABORATIVE COURTS, TO
DIVERSION, TO DRUG COURTS AND
THE LIKE. UNFORTUNATELY, IN
CALIFORNIA, THOSE COURTS HAVE
IMPLODED ALL OVER THE STATE.
THEY'VE IMPLODED. THEY'RE NO
LONGER WHERE THEY WERE EVEN FIVE
YEARS AGO. THERE ARE MANY
REASONS FOR THAT. BUT ONE
REASON, I BELIEVE, IS BECAUSE
THE INCENTIVE TO GO TO
DIVERSION, THE INCENTIVE TO GO
TO THE COLLABORATIVE COURTS
DOESN'T EXIST ANYMORE BECAUSE
THE RESULT IS THE SAME. WHETHER
YOU, FOR EXAMPLE, GO TO
COLLABORATIVE COURT AND SPEND A
YEAR HAVING TO APPEAR IN FRONT
OF THE COURT REPEATEDLY, DRUG
TESTING ALL THE LIKE. THEN AT
THE END OF THAT EXPERIENCE, IF
YOU SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETE IT,
YOUR CONVICTION IS GONE. IT'S
ERASED, AND YOU DON'T HAVE THAT
SCARLET LETTER. AND I THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT. THAT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO DO, BUT
IF THE RESULT IS EXACTLY THE
SAME, WHETHER YOU DO OR DO NOT
GO TO COLLABORATIVE COURT, THEN
FOLKS UNDERSTANDABLY DON'T GO
AND IS ILLUSTRATED IN THE
ANALYSIS THIS THIS DOES INCREASE
PENALTIES AND IT DOES INCREASE
THE COST. SO YOU CAN SEE THAT IN
THE ANALYSIS. SO WE NEED TO VOTE
FOR THIS I'M GOING TO VOTE FOR
IT. BUT WE NEED TO VOTE FOR IT
WITH OUR EYES WIDE OPEN. BECAUSE
WHAT THIS DOES I THINK IS IT
MODIFIES PROP 47, PROP 47 WAS
WELL WRITTEN. WHETHER WE AGREE
WITH IT OR NOT. IT WAS VERY WELL
WRITTEN AND VERY, VERY CLEAR.
PERMISSION TO READ MADAM
PRESIDENT? WITHOUT OBJECTION,
THE PROP 47 SAYS THAT THE ACT
SHALL BE BROADLY CONSTRUED TO
ACCOMPLISH ITS PURPOSES. THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS MEASURE BE
AMENDED BY TWO THIRDS VOTE OF
THE MEMBERS OF EACH HOUSE OF
LEGISLATURE AND SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR, SO LONG AS THE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONSISTENT WITH,
AND FURTHER THE INTENT OF THE
ACT, THE LEGISLATURE MAY, BY
MAJORITY VOTE AMEND, ADD OR
REPEAL PROVISIONS TO FURTHER
REDUCE THE PENALTIES FOR ANY
OFFENSES ADDRESSED BY THIS ACT.
SO THE CHALLENGE IS THAT THIS
WELL MAY BE INFIRM, WELL MAY BE
INFIRM. WHAT THAT MEANS IS, IS
THAT THE WORK IS NOT DONE, OUR
WORK IS NOT DONE. OUR WORK IS
NOT DONE TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
INCENTIVE AND THE DISINCENTIVE
TO, FOR EXAMPLE, EARLY ON TO
ADDRESS ISSUES CONCERNING CRIME,
TO ADDRESS ISSUES CONCERNING
SHOPLIFTING, TO ADDRESS ISSUES,
ESPECIALLY CONCERNING MINOR
CRIMES, THAT INDIVIDUALS THEN
AVAIL THEMSELVES AND THE COURTS
PROVIDE THE RESOURCES AND
PROVIDE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DIVERT. AND SO I'LL VOTE AYE,
BUT WE HAVE TO HAVE OUR EYES
WIDE OPEN THAT THE WORK HERE IS
NOT DONE. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I URGE AND I VOTE
THANK YOU, SENATOR. SEEING NO
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE,
SENATOR WIENER, YOU MAY CLOSE. I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU,
COLLEAGUES, FOR THE DEBATE. TO
MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES, I
HAVE ENORMOUS RESPECT FOR YOU
AND FOR YOUR PERSPECTIVE AND I
LARGELY SHARE THAT PERSPECTIVE.
FOR THE LAST EIGHT YEARS, I HAVE
SERVED ON THE SENATE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE, ALONG WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BERKELEY AND MY
COLLEAGUE FROM GARDENA, AND
OTHERS HAVE COME IN AND GONE.
AND OVER THAT PERIOD WE HAVE
PRODUCED LEGISLATION TO REDUCE
INCARCERATION, SOME AGGRESSIVE
LEGISLATION TO REDUCE
INCARCERATION. I HAVE SPENT TIME
ON THE ON THE GREEN CARPET
TRYING TO SQUEEZE OUT THAT 41ST
VOTE ON VARIOUS BILLS OVER TIME
TO DO THAT, SENATOR FROM
BERKELEY, SENATOR FROM GARDENA.
WE'VE WE HAVE DONE ENORMOUS WORK
FOR YEARS TO REDUCE
INCARCERATION. WE HAVE ALSO IN
THAT COMMITTEE BILLS THAT HAVE
NOT BEEN ON THIS FLOOR, THAT WE
HAVE STOPPED BILLS THAT WERE
DESIGNED TO TEAR APART PROP 47,
BILLS THAT WERE DESIGNED TO
REVERSE THAT PROGRESS. AND WE
HAVE ALL TAKEN A LOT OF
POLITICAL HEAT. I CONTINUE TO
THIS DAY TO GET BEATEN UP IN MY
DISTRICT BECAUSE OF THE BILLS
THAT WE HAVE STOPPED IN THAT
COMMITTEE, BUT WE DO HAVE A REAL
ISSUE, AND I THINK THAT THIS
BILL IS A MEASURED APPROACH THAT
HAD AN ENORMOUS STAKEHOLDER
INPUT, AND I THINK IT DOES
DESERVE SUPPORT. WHILE I DO HAVE
ENORMOUS, EXCUSE ME, ENORMOUS
RESPECT FOR THOSE WHO DO NOT
SHARE MY VIEW ON THIS BILL, AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN Ã ALVARADO GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI AYE. DODD. AYE D'ORAZIO.
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD
AYE. LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE MIN. AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE NEELO. AYE.
OKOBO. AYE PODIUM. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH HI. AYE.
RUBIO AYE. SATO. AYE SKINNER.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS STERN. UMBERG
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE.
WILK AYE. SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS.
SKINNER SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. NÓ
STERN. AYES 36. NOES ONE. THE
BILL PASSES. SENATORS, WE ARE
MOVING BACK TO THE FRONT OF OUR
CALENDAR OR OUR AGENDA HERE.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ. MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL DEEMED READ
REPORTS OF COMMITTEE WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. MOVED ON TO MOTIONS,
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES. THIS IS
THE TIME TO RAISE YOUR MIC. IF
YOU HAVE ANYTHING UNDER THIS
SECTION. SENATOR JONES, YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR, PLEASE REMOVE FILE ITEM
315 AB 2337 BY ASSEMBLYWOMAN
DIXON FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
FOR FURTHER AMENDMENTS. THE DESK
WOULD NOTE SENATOR LAIRD. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR, PLEASE
REMOVE FILE ITEM 292 AB 2058
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR FOR
THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS. THE
DESK HAS NOTED. SENATOR ROTH.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. AT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR,
PLEASE REMOVE ASSEMBLY BILL 382,
FILE ITEM NUMBER LOOKS LIKE 837.
FOR PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS AND
AB 832 FILE ITEM 836 FROM THE
CALENDAR. THANK YOU. SENATOR.
SENATOR CAVALLERO. Þ. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT, AT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR, I'D
LIKE TO REMOVE FILE ITEM NUMBER
327 AB 2721. AND AT THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR, FILE ITEM NUMBER
318 AB 2430. THANK YOU. SENATOR.
SENATOR SMALLWOOD CUEVAS THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT, ON BEHALF
OF AUTHOR, I REQUEST THAT AB
3067 BE PULLED FROM THE CONSENT
FILE FOR THE PURPOSES OF
AMENDMENT AND THAT AB 2833 BE
MOVED TO THE INACTIVE FILE. THE
DESK IS NOTED. SENATOR LIMÓN
THANK YOU. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RETURN SB 675 TO THE
ASSEMBLY FOR FURTHER ACTION.
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SENATOR WAHAB,
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PHIL TING,
PLEASE REMOVE FILE ITEM NUMBER
297 AB 1413 FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FOR THE PURPOSES OF
AMENDMENTS, THE DESK IS NOTED.
SENATOR GLAZER. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. AT THE REQUEST OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRYANT, I'D LIKE
TO PULL ASSEMBLY BILL 2664, FILE
ITEM 325 FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FOR PURPOSES OF
AMENDMENTS, THE DESK IS NOTED.
SENATOR ALVARADO HILL. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR, PLEASE
REMOVE FILE ITEM 329. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2859. AUTHOR JIM PATTERSON
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR. FOR
PURPOSES OF AMENDMENT, THE DESK
IS NOTED. SENATOR SHAKESPEARE.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. AT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR,
PLEASE REMOVE FILE ITEM 331 AB
2897 FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THANK YOU. SENATOR. MAJORITY
LEADER, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I RISE TO
REMOVE FILE ITEM Ã 21 AB 1524.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWENTHAL FROM
THE INACTIVE FILE. AND I ALSO
RISE TO REMOVE ON BEHALF OF SOME
ASSEMBLY MAJORITY LEADER
AGUIAR-CURRY FILE ITEM 311 AB
2174 AND FILE ITEM 321 AB 2606
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR. THE
DESK IS NOTED FOR AMENDMENT
MOTION. THERE ARE FOUR
AMENDMENTS AT THE DESK. THEY
WILL BE DEEMED ADOPTED PURSUANT
TO SENATE RULE 29.10 B. THE
FOLLOWING BILLS ARE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON RULES FOR ITEM
285 AB 3184. MOVING BACK TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE,
WE HAVE ITEMS ONE THROUGH FOUR.
ON THE SECOND READING FILE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2541. SECOND TO
THIRD 1936. SECOND TO THIRD 2340
SECOND TO THIRD 2599. SECOND TO
THIRD. SECOND. READING FILE IS
DEEMED READ. WE HAVE THREE
APPOINTMENTS UNDER GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS. IT IS TIME FOR
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS. SENATOR
GROVE IS ALMOST READY. SENATOR
GROVE IS READY. WE'RE GOING TO
START A FILE. ITEM NUMBER SEVEN,
SENATOR GROVE. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. WHILE ITEM SEVEN IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF DAVID HOLT
SHIELD FOR THE REAPPOINTMENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION, HE WAS FIRST
APPOINTED IN 2013, AND HE SERVED
AS THE COMMISSION'S CHAIR SINCE
2019. PRIOR TO THIS, HE WAS A
SOLAR COMPANY EXECUTIVE AND
SERVED IN THE SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
RESPECTFULLY ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR. SEEING
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE,
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE. ALVARADO. GILL AYE.
ARCHULETA AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER AYE.
BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALY DODD. AYE.
DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER.
AYE GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD. AYE.
LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR I MEAN AYE. NEWMAN.
AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NIELLO AYE.
OCHOA AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROD AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO SKINNER. AYE. SMALL.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER I WILL AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS. DALLEY GROVE. AYE SATO.
STERN. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE
TIME. ATKINS DALLEY. SATO STERN.
AYES 36. NO. ZERO. THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED.
SENATOR GROVE IS PREPARED FOR
ITEM EIGHT. PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU. MADAM PRESIDENT. FILE
ITEM EIGHT IS THE CONFIRMATION
OF MARY LESLIE FOR REAPPOINTMENT
TO THE CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT
SYSTEM OPERATING GOVERNING
BOARD. MISS LESLIE WAS APPROVED
BY THE RULES COMMITTEE ON A50
VOTE ON JULY 3RD. SHE WAS
APPOINTED IN 2019 AND PREVIOUSLY
SERVED AS THE BOARD'S CHAIR.
THIS IS SOMEBODY WE REALLY WANT
AT THE HELM OF THE ISO. SHE WAS
INCREDIBLE, SHE ANSWERED EVERY
QUESTION, TOUGH QUESTIONS,
THINGS ABOUT THE FUTURE WHERE
WE'RE GOING WITH ENERGY. NØ
NOTES, UNDERSTANDS THE SYSTEM
FROM BEGINNING TO END, AND WE
SHOULD BE HONORED TO VOTE FOR
HER. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. I'M SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. AYE ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE ATKINS. BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD.
AYE CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLEY AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE.
HURTADO. AYE JONES. AYE. LAIRD
AYE. LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN. AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN AYE. NEELO AYE.
OKOBO. AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO AYE. SKINNER I SMILED.
CUEVAS. AYE STERN. UMBERG. AYE
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK.
AYE AYES 38. NO ZERO. THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED. FILE
ITEM IN THIS SECTION. FILE ITEM
TEN. SENATOR GROVE IS PREPARED,
PLEASE. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. THE CONFIRMATION OF
JEFF MARINA, THE DIRECTOR OF
OFFICE OF DATA AND INNOVATION
WAS JUST ESTABLISHED LAST YEAR.
THIS APPOINTMENT CONFIRMATION IS
VERY, VERY INTERESTING. WHEN HE
CAME BEFORE US IN THE RULES
COMMITTEE, HE'S ACTUALLY VERY
GOOD AT AT TECHNOLOGY AND THINGS
LIKE THAT. AND WHEN WE HAD A
PROBLEM WITH COVID AND THE
RESPONSE TO COVID, HE CAME IN
AND VOLUNTEERED FROM AN OUTSIDE
SOURCE AS A BUSINESS LEADER IN
THIS ARENA. AND HE VOLUNTEERED
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
2020, 2020 TO BRING THIS
EXPERTISE TO THE STATE'S COVID
19 PANDEMIC RESPONSE. HE HELD
MULTIPLE LEADERSHIP POSITIONS,
HELPING EVERY AGENCY THAT NEEDED
HELP WITH THE RESPONSE AND HOW
TO TAKE CARE OF OUR CONSTITUENTS
AT THE BEST OF THE STATE'S
ABILITY. HE BROUGHT EXPERTISE TO
EVERY ONE OF OUR AGENCIES WITH
THE RESPONSE, HE FACILITATED
DATA TRANSACTIONS, ALL
VOLUNTEERING HIS TIME. AND HAS
THAT, THAT LEADERSHIP AND THAT
COMPASSION FOR OUR STATE HAS LED
HIM TO BE APPOINTED TO THIS
POSITION AS THE OFFICE OF DATA
INNOVATION, AND HE WAS APPROVED
BY THE RULES COMMITTEE ON JULY
3RD WITH A50 VOTE. RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE, SENATOR DODD.
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT, I'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH
DIRECTOR MARINO AS CHAIR OF THE
GEO COMMITTEE ON NUMEROUS I
BILLS. MY OWN AND OTHERS, AND I
CAME AWAY JUST SO INCREDIBLY
IMPRESSED BY, NOT ONLY HIS
KNOWLEDGE, BUT HIS COMMITMENT
AND HIS PASSION. I'M SURE HE IS
GOING TO DO AN OUTSTANDING JOB.
URGE YOUR AYE. VOTE. THANK YOU.
SEE NO FURTHER DISCUSSION.
DEBATE. SENATOR GROVE, YOU MAY
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AND AYE VOTE. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN. AYE. I'LL
RODA-GIL. AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS BECKER. AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER AYE. BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLEY AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. AYE HURTADO.
JONES. AYE LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN
AYE. MAGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE
MINH. AYE. NEWMAN. AYE NGUYEN.
AYE. MELO AYE. OKOBO AYE.
BADILLO AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH. AYE RUBIO. AYE. SATO. AYE.
SKINNER. I SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK. AYE. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS.
REDONDO. AYE STERN. AYES 38. NO,
ZERO. THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED. WE HAVE ONE ITEM
UNDER UNFINISHED BUSINESS BY
MAJORITY LEADER. ITEM NUMBER 12.
SHE IS PREPARED. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL 674 BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ. AN ACT
RELATING TO AIR POLLUTION.
MAJORITY LEADER. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. MEMBERS.
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS TO SB 674
ARE AS FOLLOWS. REWORK Kò
DEFINITIONS. CLARIFY THAT
REFINERIES AND RELATED
FACILITIES ARE ONLY RESPONSIBLE
FOR MONITORING THEIR OWN
EMISSIONS. PROVIDE THAT FENCE
LINE MONITORING IS NOT REQUIRED
WHEN THERE AREN'T COMMUNITIES
NEARBY, AND DELAY IMPLEMENTATION
TO ENSURE THAT THE PROGRAM IS
IMPLEMENTED CORRECTLY AND WITH
ADEQUATE PUBLIC INVOLVEMENT.
THESE AMENDMENTS ADDRESS MANY OF
THE OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS AND
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY
WHERE APPROPRIATE, WHILE
ENSURING THAT COMMUNITIES ARE
RECEIVING ADEQUATE PROTECTIONS
AND INFORMATION. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON
CONCURRENT. THANK YOU SENATOR.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE,
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE. ALL VOTED GILL NØ
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE
ATKINS. BECKER. AYE BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO CORTEZ. AYE. DALLI NÓ.
DODD DORADO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER. AYE GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
NO. HURTADO JONES. NO. LAIRD
AYE. LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE AYE.
MENGIBAR. AYE MEN. AYE NEWMAN.
NGUYEN NO. NILO. NO OJOBO. NO.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO. NO
SKINNER. AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS
CABALLERO. AYE DODD. AYE HURTADO.
NEWMAN STERN EYES, 28. KNOWS A
ASSEMBLY. AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE BACK TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. MAJORITY LEADER.
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. YES. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUBMIT A
LETTER TO THE SENATE JOURNAL
REGARDING SENATE BILL 674, WHICH
WILL CLARIFY THE BILL'S INTENT
THAT COVERED FACILITIES THAT ARE
ENTIRELY ENCLOSED WITHIN THE
FOOTPRINT OF A REFINERY ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO DO MONITORING. UNDER
THE BILL, BOTH SIDES HAVE
REVIEWED AND APPROVED THE
LETTER. AND I THANK YOU, SENATOR
LIMÓN. YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU. I'D LIKE TO REMOVE AB 1930
FILE ITEM 304 FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FOR PURPOSES OF
AMENDMENTS WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SUCH WILL BE THE ORDER MOVING
BACK, MOVING BACK AND FORWARD,
TO US SENATE THIRD READING. NO.
WE HAVE TWO ITEMS UNDER SENATE.
THIRD READING, FILE ITEM 20 AND
FILE ITEM 24. SENATOR TROBO,
YOU'RE KICKING US OFF. SHE IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 146
BY SENATOR TROBO RELATIVE TO
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY CATS DAY.
SENATOR TROBO, THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS, I RISE
TO PRESENT SCR 146, WHICH
RECOGNIZES TODAY, AUGUST 8TH AS
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY CATS DAY.
YES. COMMUNITY CATS TODAY,
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO MANY
ANIMAL SHELTERS AND
ORGANIZATIONS WHOSE MISSION IS
TO PROTECT THE WELFARE OF
ANIMALS, INCLUDING COMMUNITY
CATS, A TERM USED TO DESCRIBE
OUTDOOR, UNOWNED, FREE ROAMING
CATS THAT CAN BE TAMED, FERAL,
HEALTHY, SICK, ALTERED, OR
UNALTERED. CATS CAN HAVE OR CATS
HAVE HELD A SPECIAL PLACE IN MY
HEART. MY FAMILY ADOPTED TWO
CATS FROM THE COMMUNITY, MAC AND
SAMMY. THEY BROUGHT JOY AND A
LITTLE MISCHIEF TO OUR HOME, BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY, THEY BROUGHT
LOVE. THEIR PLAYFUL ANTICS
WARMED OUR HOME. I'M SORRY
THEY'RE BOTH PASSED AWAY. THEIR
PLAYFUL ANTICS WARMED OUR HOME,
AND I'M PLEASED TO INTRODUCE
THIS RESOLUTION TO RAISE
AWARENESS ABOUT COMMUNITY CATS.
BECAUSE THE MORE WE KNOW, THE
BETTER WE CAN MANAGE THE UNOWNED
CATS LIVING IN EVERY CITY IN
CALIFORNIA. THE MAIN FACTOR IN
THE HIGH POPULATION OF COMMUNITY
CATS IS UNCONTROLLED.
REPRODUCTION TO HELP CONTROL THE
CAT POPULATION, MANY AGENCIES
ARE USING TRAP, NEUTER RETURN OR
TNR, A NON-LETHAL METHOD IN
WHICH CATS ARE HUMANELY TRAPPED,
SPAYED, OR NEUTERED, VACCINATED,
AND EAR TIPPED BY VETERINARIANS
AND THEN EITHER ADOPTED OR IF
SAFE, RETURNED TO THE COMMUNITY.
THE TNR APPROACH HAS PROVEN
EFFECTIVE IN REDUCING NUISANCE
BEHAVIORS AND KEEPING COMMUNITY
CATS HEALTHIER AND SAFER. SCR
146 COMMENDS ANIMAL RESCUE
ORGANIZATIONS AND SHELTERS CAT
ADVOCATES AND VOLUNTEERS FOR
RESCUING ADOPTABLE CATS AND
HUMANELY CONTROLLING THE
COMMUNITY. CAT POPULATION IN
THEIR JURISDICTIONS, THEREBY
SAVING THOUSANDS OF CATS EVERY
YEAR. I URGE ALL CALIFORNIANS TO
GET INVOLVED IN SOME WAY BY
DONATIONS, ADOPTIONS, VOLUNTEER
HOURS. ANY INVOLVEMENT WILL HELP
LOCAL ANIMAL ORGANIZATIONS
BETTER MANAGE COMMUNITY CATS IN
THEIR REGIONS. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
RECOGNIZING AUGUST 8TH, 2024, AS
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY CATS DAY.
SENATOR EGGMAN, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED FOR THE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT. I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS. AND
WHILE PEOPLE MAY KNOW THAT I
LOVE DOGS, I HAVE TWO DOGS. I AM
ALSO A CAT LADY, AND I HAVE TWO
CATS, SOURDOUGH, MISTY AND ASHY
ROSE. AND ON BEHALF OF THEM, AND
I'M GLAD TO KNOW THAT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM YUCAIPA IS ALSO A
CAT LADY. SO ON BEHALF OF ALL
CAT LADIES, I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. SENATOR LAIRD, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I WAS JUST GOING TO
SAY I'M AN OLDER MAN WITH NO
CHILDREN AND A CAT. I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION. SENATOR
MIN, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED, I JUST
WANT TO, APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD.
I'M A CAT, DAD. IN ADDITION TO
MY THREE YOUNG KIDS, I HAVE A
CAT. I'VE UNFORTUNATELY SEEN TWO
PREVIOUS CATS THAT HAVE PASSED.
I KNOW THEY'RE AN IMPORTANT PART
OF OUR FAMILY. LET'S GO. CATS
SEE NO FURTHER. CAT LOVERS. WE
ARE NOW. SENATOR TRUMBO. YOU MAY
CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS, ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTION? AYES 38. NO, ZERO.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED FOR
ITEM 24. SENATOR ALVARADO IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 167
BY SENATOR ALVARADO GIL.
RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA, ONE AWAY
AND HOMELESS YOUTH PREVENTION
MONTH. SENATOR, THANK YOU SO
MUCH, MADAM PRESIDENT. I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 167, WHICH
WOULD DESIGNATE THIS NOVEMBER AS
RUNAWAY AND HOMELESS YOUTH
PREVENTION MONTH. HERE IN THE
GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THIS
RESOLUTION IS DESIGNED TO RAISE
AWARENESS ABOUT THE NUMBER OF
YOUTH WHO DON'T HAVE A SAFE AND
STABLE PLACE TO CALL THEIR HOME,
OFTEN SLEEPING ON THE STREETS
AND SHELTERS, RUNNING AWAY,
BEING KICKED OUT AND COUCH
SURFING. IN CALIFORNIA, THE
NUMBER OF UNACCOMPANIED HOMELESS
YOUTH IS 10,173, AND THERE ARE
2219 PARENTING YOUTH AND THEIR
CHILDREN EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. BASED ON THE US
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND URBAN
DEVELOPMENT'S 2023 PIT, OR POINT
IN TIME HOMELESS COUNT, FINDINGS
FROM CHAPIN HALL FOUND THAT 1 IN
10 YOUNG ADULTS AGES 18 TO 25,
AND AT LEAST 1 IN 30 ADOLESCENTS
AGES 13 TO 17 EXPERIENCED SOME
FORM OF HOMELESSNESS
UNACCOMPANIED BY A PARENT OR A
GUARDIAN. OVER THE COURSE OF A
YEAR, OUR HOMELESS YOUTH ARE
MUCH MORE LIKELY TO BE
UNSHELTERED THAN ADULT HOMELESS
PEOPLE, AND OUR BLACK AND LATINO
AND LGBTQ YOUTH ARE ALSO
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED,
ACCOUNTING FOR ABOUT 40% OF
HOMELESS YOUTH. OTHER REPORTS
FIND THAT 50% OF CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS POPULATIONS HAD THEIR
FIRST EXPERIENCE OF
HOMELESSNESS. WHEN THEY WERE
ONLY UNDER THE AGE OF 25, WITH
FEW RESOURCES AND LITTLE
SUPPORT, OUR RUNAWAY AND
HOMELESS YOUTH OFTEN FALL
VICTIMS TO SEXUAL EXPLOITATION,
VIOLENT CRIMES, AND EXTREME
POVERTY. THE LEGISLATURE HAS
TAKEN IMPORTANT STEPS TO ENSURE
THAT THE HOMELESS YOUTH ARE
SERVED BY THE HOMELESS HOUSING
ASSISTANCE AND PREVENTION
PROGRAM. FUNDING FOR HAP AND
HOMEKEY AND MORE CAN BE DONE SO
THAT NO YOUNG PERSON HAS TO LAY
THEIR HEAD ON THE COLD GROUND TO
SLEEP AT NIGHT TO CONTINUE THE
INCREASE AWARENESS FOR OUR YOUTH
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS, AND
AS CHAIR OF THE HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE, I ASK THAT YOU PLEASE
JOIN ME IN DECLARING NOVEMBER
2024 AS CALIFORNIA'S 13TH ANNUAL
RUNAWAY AND HOMELESS YOUTH
PREVENTION MONTH. TOGETHER, WE
WILL ENSURE SUPPORTIVE AND
EFFECTIVE PROGRAMS ARE CREATED
THROUGH THIS STATE TO STOP OUR
CHILDREN FROM ENTERING THE
PIPELINE INTO CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS. THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE,
THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTION? AYES 37. NO ZERO. THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. WE HAVE
NOW UNDER SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR NUMBER 43. WE ARE GOING
TO BE LIFTING A CALL FIRST FOR
FINAL ITEM 27. WE'RE LIFTING THE
CALL FOR SR 105. SENATOR NEWMAN.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS
DALLEY, NGUYEN. OKOBO. STERN
WILK. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ATKINS. DALLEY AYE.
NGUYEN AYE. OKOBO STERN. WILK
AQUEBOGUE. AYE. OKAY. AYES 37.
NO. ZERO RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
ADOPTED. NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
SPECIAL CONSENT. CALENDAR NUMBER
43. WE HAVE ITEMS 344 THROUGH
347. IS THERE ANYONE THAT WISHES
TO PULL AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR? SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ ALL THE
ITEMS. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION 2052092 12 214.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON THE FIRST ITEM. ALLEN ELROD.
GILL AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY
AYE. ATKINS. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER AYE. BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI AYE. DODD BARRASSO. EGGMAN
AYE. GLAZER AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE AYE OR DATO. AYE. JONES
AYE. LAIRD. AYE LIMÓN. AYE.
MAGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE NGUYEN. AYE.
NHIÀU AYE. COBO AYE. PADILLA
AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE ROTH AYE.
RUBIO AYE. SERRATO AYE. SKINNER
I SMILED. CUEVAS AYE. STERN.
UMBERG AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER.
AYE WILK. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ATKINS DODD. AYE
DURAZZO. AYE STERN. WILK AYES
37. NO. ZERO. THE CONSENT
CALENDAR PASSES. RETURNING TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. THIS IS
OUR TIME TO DO OUR ADJOURN IN
MEMORIES. WE HAVE THREE. TODAY
WE'RE GOING TO START OFF WITH
SENATOR RUBIO. VIÆT. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE, TODAY I
RISE TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
DOCTOR ROBERT H. SUZUKI,
LOVINGLY KNOWN AS BOB. HE'S A
FORMER UNIVERSITY PRESIDENT OF
CAL POLY POMONA WHO PASSED AT
THE AGE OF 88 WHEN HE WAS A
CHILD. DURING WORLD WAR TWO, BOB
AND HIS FAMILY WERE CONFINED IN
IDAHO IN AN INTERNMENT CAMP FOR
JAPANESE AMERICANS. BOB'S
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCE SHAPED HIM
IN BECOMING AN ACTIVIST WHO WAS
DEEPLY INVOLVED IN THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT, ADVOCATING FOR
MINORITY GROUPS IN SOCIETY.
ALONGSIDE HIS WIFE AGNES, BOB
BECAME AN AGENT FOR CHANGE,
PICKETING, RALLYING, AND
ORGANIZING FOR ACTION, LEADING A
NATIONAL CAMPAIGN FOR THE
CONGRESSIONAL REPEAL OF THE
EMERGENCY DETENTION ACT OF 1950.
ALTHOUGH HE BEGAN HIS CAREER AS
AN ENGINEER, BOB CHOSE TO PURSUE
A CAREER IN EDUCATION, WHICH WAS
MORE IN LINE TO HIS COMMITMENT
TO SOCIAL JUSTICE AND COMMUNITY
BUILDING. DURING HIS TIME AS
PRESIDENT OF CAL POLY POMONA,
BOB WAS ABLE TO RAISE MORE THAN
$110 MILLION TO HELP FUND
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS ON CAMPUS
AND EXPAND OPPORTUNITIES FOR
STUDENTS RESOURCES SUCH AS
SCHOLARSHIP OPPORTUNITIES TO
HELP PAY FOR COLLEGE FOR THOSE
THAT NEEDED THE MOST. BOB WAS AN
AMAZING MAN WHO WAS RECOGNIZED,
AND HIS WORK FOR ANTI-RACIST,
ANTI-OPPRESSION AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE. WORK. HE SERVED AS A
MEMBER ON THE NATIONAL SCIENCE
BOARD AND THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT
AID COMMISSION. THE NATIONAL
CONFERENCE ON RACE AND ETHNICITY
IN HIGHER EDUCATION HONORED HIM
IN 2016. THE SAN GABRIEL VALLEY
ECONOMIC PARTNERSHIP AWARDED HIM
ITS FINAL FIRST ANNUAL
TECHNOLOGY LEADERSHIP AWARD. IN
2001, PRESIDENT BILL CLINTON
NAMED HIM TO SERVE ON THE
NATIONAL SCIENCE FOUNDATION IN
1997. IN ADDITION, BOB WAS A
FIRST RECIPIENT OF THE NATIONAL
EDUCATION ASSOCIATION'S HUMAN
RIGHTS AWARD FOR LEADERSHIP IN
ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER AFFAIRS
IN 1976. BOB WAS AN INSPIRATION
TO THOSE WHO KNEW HIM, AND HE
DEEPLY CARED FOR HIS STUDENTS.
HE ALWAYS MADE TIME AND WAS
ALWAYS VERY EMPATHETIC TO THEIR
NEEDS. HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS
WIFE, AGNES, HIS THREE CHILDREN,
AND HIS GRANDCHILDREN. PLEASE
JOIN ME IN ADJOURNING IN THE
MEMORY OF BOB SUZUKI. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT. THANK YOU
SENATOR. PLEASE BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD. SO THAT WE MAY PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZE THEM IN THE JOURNAL.
SENATOR ROTH, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
FRIENDS, I ASK THAT YOU JOIN ME
THIS MORNING IN A JOURNEY IN
MEMORY OF ROBERT SWAN. BOB WAS A
DEAR FRIEND OF MINE AND OUR
FAMILY AND A TRUE PUBLIC
SERVANT. HE SERVED WITH
DISTINCTION, COMMITMENT, AND
DEDICATION AS A TRUSTEE ON THE
ALVORD UNIFIED SCHOOL BOARD FOR
THE PAST DECADE AND ELECTED AS
ITS PRESIDENT THREE TIMES. A
PRODUCT OF ALVORD SCHOOLS, HE
WAS CONSIDERED TO BE A TREASURE
IN OUR REGION. HE PLAYED A
SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN LEADING THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT DURING THE COVID
19 PANDEMIC, WORKED TO NARROW
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS AND PREPARE
STUDENTS FOR COLLEGE AND
CAREERS. WHEN HE RETIRED FROM
AT&T AFTER 31 YEARS OF SERVICE,
HE IMMERSED HIMSELF IN OUR
COMMUNITY. HE WAS INTRINSICALLY
INVOLVED IN THE FABRIC OF OUR
REGION, BUILDING BRIDGES AND
FORMING PARTNERSHIPS TO GET
THINGS DONE. HE MET HIS LOVELY
WIFE, BETH, WHILE THEY WERE
STUDENTS AT RIVERSIDE'S LA
SIERRA HIGH SCHOOL. HE WAS A
JUNIOR AND SHE WAS A FRESHMAN.
THEY WOULD HAVE CELEBRATED THEIR
42ND ANNIVERSARY THIS OCTOBER.
CINDY AND I SEND OUR LOVE AND
PRAYERS TO BETH, THEIR CHILDREN,
GRANDCHILDREN DURING THIS MOST
DIFFICULT TIME. WE WILL MISS HIM
A LOT. THANK YOU SENATOR. PLEASE
BRING HIS NAME FORWARD SO THAT
WE MAY PROPERLY MEMORIALIZE
ROBERT IN THE JOURNAL. OUR FINAL
AIM OF THE DAY IS GOING TO BE
FROM SENATOR WAHAB. SENATOR
WAHAB, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU. COLLEAGUES, I RISE TO
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF ELAINE
ALQUIST, THE FIRST GREEK
AMERICAN WOMAN TO SERVE IN BOTH
THE ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE.
ELAINE WORKED TIRELESSLY AS AN
ADVOCATE FOR VULNERABLE YOUTH
AND SENIORS. ONE OF HER
SIGNATURE PIECES OF LEGISLATION
WAS THE SILVER ALERT FOR MISSING
SENIORS. AND I WILL GO OVER IT
VERY, VERY BRIEFLY. HER TIME AS
A SCHOOL TEACHER, THEN COUNSELOR
AND MEMBER OF THE CUPERTINO
UNION SCHOOL DISTRICT BOARD OF
EDUCATION, INFORMED HER
STATEWIDE POLICY MAKING EFFORTS
TO IMPROVE PUBLIC EDUCATION. IN
ALL, SHE SPENT TWO DECADES
SERVING THE PEOPLE AS AN ELECTED
OFFICIAL. ELAINE ALQUIST PASSED
AWAY ON JULY 9TH AT THE AGE OF
79, IN SANTA CLARA, CALIFORNIA.
SHE WAS A MOTHER TO SONS PETER
AND BRIAN WHITE, GRANDMOTHER TO
JASMINE, LOGAN, AND LIAM WHITE,
AND PARTNER TO JAY DUNCAN.
VENICE SENATOR ALQUIST WAS A
TRAILBLAZER AND A ROLE MODEL FOR
SO MANY. MAY SHE REST IN PEACE.
THANK YOU SENATOR CORTESE.
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT. I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
HAYWARD LEADING THIS ADJOURNMENT
IN MEMORY FOR ELAINE ALQUIST,
PARTICULARLY BECAUSE ELAINE, WHO
I KNEW, I'M ALWAYS HESITANT TO
DATE MYSELF. I GOT TO GET OVER
THAT. BUT I'M GOING ALL THE WAY
BACK TO THE 1990S. THAT SAID,
SHE WAS A CITY OF SANTA CLARA
PERSON. WE'RE SANTA CLARA COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES. MANY OF US IN
THE DELEGATION FROM DOWN THERE.
BUT SHE WAS SUCH A CITY OF SANTA
CLARA PERSON. AND ONE OF OUR
EARLY WOMEN CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATORS THAT I THINK SHE WOULD
BE VERY, VERY PROUD TO HAVE OUR
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM HAYWARD AND
SANTA CLARA REALLY LEADING THIS
MEMORIAL TODAY. I'M GOING TO BE
JUST A LITTLE BIT MORE
ANECDOTAL, I THINK, BUT TO TRY
TO PUT SOME THINGS IN
PERSPECTIVE, AS OUR COLLEAGUE
JUST INDICATED, HER THING WAS
EDUCATION. SHE HAD COME FROM A
SCHOOL BOARD BACKGROUND, I
BELIEVE, OVER IN CUPERTINO ON
THAT SIDE OF WHAT IS NOW SOME
COMBINATION OF SENATE DISTRICT
15 AND A COUPLE OF OTHER SENATE
DISTRICTS THAT MAYBE THREE OF US
REPRESENT AT THIS TIME, BUT THAT
WASN'T IT. AND I WAS ALWAYS
TAKEN BY THE FACT THAT DESPITE
THE FACT THAT SHE HAD THIS VERY
URBAN, BACKGROUND, CUPERTINO,
SANTA CLARA LIVED IN SANTA CLARA,
REPRESENTED THAT AREA. SHE HAD A
STRONG CONNECTION TO FARM
WORKERS, TO THE UNITED FARM
WORKERS. TO MY KNOWLEDGE, THERE
WASN'T A TIME IN HER ELECTED
REPRESENTATION THAT SHE DIDN'T
HAVE STAFF AND ADVISORS HELPING
HER TO DEVELOP HER POLICY AROUND
ASSISTANCE TO FARM WORKERS WHO
WERE BY THAT TIME OF COURSE,
VERY MUCH CONNECTED TO THE
SOUTHERN PART OF SANTA CLARA
COUNTY, AND THEN ALL THE WAY
DOWN TO SALINAS AND SO FORTH.
THAT WAS THE PHYSICAL OR
GEOGRAPHIC CONNECTION. BUT THAT
DIDN'T STOP HER FROM MAKING THAT
CONNECTION IN HER OWN OFFICE AND
BEING A FIGHTER FOR THEIR
RIGHTS. THE OTHER THING, AGAIN,
JUST TO KIND OF PUT THINGS IN
PERSPECTIVE FOR SOME WHO GO BACK
A LITTLE FURTHER, LIKE A COUPLE
OF US, BUT ALSO THOSE WHO ARE
NEWER AND REMEMBER, FOLKS WHO
CAME AFTER HER, ELAINE'S HUSBAND
WAS FORMER STATE SENATOR AL
ALQUIST, WHO HAD ALSO STARTED IN
THE STATE ASSEMBLY BEFORE TERM
LIMITS. AND HE WAS SUCCEEDED BY
A FORMER ASSEMBLY MEMBER, JOHN
VASCONCELLOS, WHO BECAME A STATE
SENATOR. ALSO IN AN ERA THAT WAS
MOSTLY GOVERNED BY A LACK OF
TERM LIMITS, BOTH OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS HAD CHAIRED WAYS AND
MEANS OR BUDGET COMMITTEES, AND
THEY WERE BOTH FROM THIS SAME
AREA, THE SAME DISTRICT OR
GEOGRAPHIC AREA. IN FACT, ELAINE
SUCCEEDED JOHN VASCONCELLOS IN
THE STATE SENATE HAD THAT NAME,
THAT SURNAME THAT WAS ICONIC
DOWN IN OUR AREA. AND SHE WAS
HER OWN PERSON. SHE WAS VERY
ASSERTIVE. SHE WAS VERY MUCH A
STRONG WOMAN IN THE STATE
SENATE, AND I KNOW THAT. AND I
KNEW HER AND SHE DIDN'T BACK OFF
EVEN OVER A CUP OF COFFEE. MANY
OF MANY OF WHICH I HAD WITH HER,
MANY OF, A MORNING I SAT DOWN
WITH HER AND, YOU KNOW, KIND OF
HEARD WHAT SHE REALLY THOUGHT.
AND I ALWAYS ADMIRED HER FOR
THAT GUMPTION, BECAUSE IN SOME
SENSE, YOU KNOW, SHE COULD HAVE
BEEN TAKEN AS JUST THE WIFE OF
THE FORMER STATE SENATOR WHO
ULTIMATELY AND EVENTUALLY TOOK
OVER THAT OFFICE. THAT WASN'T IT
AT ALL. SHE WAS HER OWN PERSON.
AND DESERVES VERY MUCH, DESERVES
TO BE RECOGNIZED TODAY AS THAT
STRONG PERSON WHO STOOD UP FOR A
VARIETY OF CONSTITUENTS AND
DEMOGRAPHICS AND ISSUES, BUT
PARTICULARLY EDUCATION. JIM
BELL, MY PREDECESSOR, CAME FROM
SORT OF THAT SAME ELECTORAL
LINEAGE. ULTIMATELY, AS DID
JERRY HILL, WHO I THINK WAS
SUCCEEDED BY, ANOTHER ONE OF OUR
COLLEAGUES HERE TODAY FROM THE
SANTA CLARA COUNTY DELEGATION.
SO I'M EXPLAINING ALL OF THAT,
JUST TO GIVE A FEEL FOR THE
LEGACY THAT SHE WAS A PART OF
THE BACKGROUND IN OUR COUNTY,
THAT SHE WAS A PART OF, AND THE
STRENGTH OF THE WOMAN WHO WE'RE
RECOGNIZING TODAY WITH THIS
MEMORIAL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
SENATOR LAIRD. YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I RISE TO IN A
TRIBUTE TO FORMER SENATOR ELAINE
ALQUIST. AND SHE AND I
OVERLAPPED NOT JUST IN SERVICE,
BUT MY ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
OVERLAPPED WITH HER SENATE
DISTRICT, AND WE WORKED TOGETHER
ON A LOT OF THE ISSUES THAT WERE
MENTIONED. WE HAD A
DISPROPORTIONATE PART OF SENIORS
IN SOME PART OF THE DISTRICT,
AND WE WORKED TOGETHER TO
ADDRESS THEIR ISSUES. WE HAD
UNBELIEVABLE WATER CONTAMINATION
WITH PERCHLORATE IN THAT PART OF
THE DISTRICT. WE WORKED REALLY
HELPED TO HARD TO PROTECT
PEOPLE'S FRESH WATER AND WATER
SUPPLY AND DRINKING WATER. IN
THAT TIME OF CRISIS, THERE WAS
AN AREA THERE, SAN MARTIN, THAT
WE SHARED THAT WANTED TO
INCORPORATE. IT GOT CAUGHT,
BETWEEN PROPOSITION ONE AND
NEWLY FORMING CITIES. I DID A
BILL WITH HER TO SIDE TO PROTECT
THE ABILITY OF THOSE RESIDENTS
TO INCORPORATE, IF THEY WANTED.
BUT ALSO, AS WAS SAID, SHE CAME
OFF OF A SCHOOL BOARD. SHE CAME
OUT OF EDUCATION, AND WE WORKED
REALLY HARD IN DIFFICULT BUDGET
TIMES TO TRY TO PROTECT
EDUCATION. SHE WAS REALLY
COMMITTED. SHE DIDN'T ALWAYS
SEEK THE HEADLINES. SHE JUST
WANTED TO GET IT DONE. AND SO I
RISE IN TRIBUTE TO THAT RECORD
TODAY. SENATOR ROTH, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I, FIRST, I GUESS,
CAME IN CONTACT WITH SENATOR
ALQUIST DURING MY 2012 CAMPAIGN
FOR THE STATE SENATE. MY FIRST
CAMPAIGN, IT WAS A DIFFICULT
TIME, AS I'VE PROBABLY TOLD YOU,
SEVERAL TIMES, I DIDN'T HAVE A
LOT OF FRIENDS. AND OUT OF THE
BLUE, ONE DAY I WAS SITTING IN
MY LAW OFFICE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA, AND I GOT A CALL AND
I PICKED UP THE PHONE AND THE
LADY ON THE OTHER END IDENTIFIED
HERSELF AS STATE SENATOR ELAINE
ALQUIST. SHE DIDN'T KNOW ME, AND
I CERTAINLY DIDN'T KNOW HER. AND
IT WAS QUITE A SURPRISE TO GET
THIS CALL. SHE SPENT A LOT OF
TIME WITH ME. SHE ASKED ABOUT MY
CAMPAIGN. SHE ASKED ABOUT MY
FUNDRAISING. WE TALKED, AND
ALTHOUGH I KNEW SHE WAS OUT OF
OFFICE BECAUSE BY THEN I KNEW
WHO THE STATE SENATORS WERE, WHO
WERE SERVING, SHE TOLD ME, SHE
SAID, YOU KNOW, I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT YOU. AND SHE DID. AND
THEN DURING THE COURSE OF THAT
PRIMARY CAMPAIGN, SHE CALLED
AGAIN TO CHECK IN. AND EVERY NOW
AND THEN I'D SEND I'D GET A
CHECK FROM HER. AND I KNEW SHE
DIDN'T HAVE ANY MONEY IN TERMS
OF POLITICAL MONEY FOR CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS, BUT SHE DUG INTO
HER OWN POCKET TO HELP SOME GUY
WHO DIDN'T HAVE A LOT OF
FRIENDS, DIDN'T HAVE THE PARTY
ENDORSEMENT, AND WAS SIMPLY
TRYING TO GET TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE. AND HER CONTRIBUTION
AND HER SUPPORT DID MAKE A
DIFFERENCE DURING THAT PRIMARY
ELECTION PERIOD. YOU KNOW, IT
SHOULDN'T HAVE SURPRISED ME THAT
SHE CALLED ME AND THAT SHE
SUPPORTED ME BECAUSE ONCE I GOT
UP HERE, I UNDERSTOOD THAT THIS
SENATE IS A TEAM. IT WAS THEN
AND IS NOW. AND ONCE A TEAM
MEMBER, YOU'RE ALWAYS A TEAM
MEMBER. AND SHE SUPPORTED THE
TEAM. SO I'LL NEVER FORGET
SENATOR ELAINE ALQUIST. AND
WE'LL MISS HER A LOT TO. I
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S COMMENTS
ON THE LATE SENATOR. SENATOR,
PLEASE BRING HER NAME FORWARD TO
THE SENATOR MAY BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED IN THE JOURNAL.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE BACK TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR FOR ONE
HOT SECOND, AND RECOGNIZE
SENATOR BECKER. THANK YOU.
COLLEAGUES, GIVE ME A GREAT
PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE MY
DAUGHTER, WHO WAS ABLE TO BE
HERE LAST NIGHT AND WITNESSED
THAT. REALLY? JUST AS I SAID,
HEARTWARMING, INSPIRING, MOVING
TRIBUTES TO OUR COLLEAGUES AND
THEIR SERVICE HERE. I'M GLAD SHE
WAS ABLE TO WITNESS THAT. PLEASE
JOIN ME IN WELCOMING MY
DAUGHTER, LEO BECKER. WELCOME
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US. IF
THERE IS NO OTHER BUSINESS, MR.
PRO TEM, THE DESK IS CLEAR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS, WE'LL
ECHO WHAT THE GOOD SENATOR FROM
THE BAY AREA HAD SAID ABOUT WHAT
AN AMAZING EVENING IT WAS. AND I
KNOW THAT WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE PAYING TRIBUTE TO THOSE
TEN RETIRING MEMBERS HERE IN THE
NEXT COUPLE OF WEEKS. WE GOT A
BUSY FEW WEEKS IN FRONT OF US.
MADAM PRESIDENT, IT IS GOING TO
BE PRODUCTIVE. WE'RE GOING TO BE
SUCCESSFUL, AND WE'RE GOING TO
START ALL OVER AGAIN. THE NEXT
FLOOR SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
MONDAY, AUGUST 12TH AT 2 P.M.
HAVE A WONDERFUL WEEKEND. THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
3:30 P.M, WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE MADE.
WE WILL RECONVENE MONDAY, AUGUST
12TH AT 2 P.M.